Can the Libertarian Party
become a major contender
that consistently wins elections?
If the organization's
dismal 50-year track record
isn't discouraging enough,
now the LP is in disarray after
its chairman and two members
of its National Committee
resigned in the wake of an attempt
to de-certify the New Hampshire affiliate
due to conflicts over its
social media presence.
This episode has revealed an
organization at war with itself
over vision, tactics, and messaging.
To get a better sense of what's going on,
Reason spoke with former Michigan
Congressman Justin Amash,
who finished his five terms in office
as the first and only libertarian
to hold national office.
He had been elected as a Republican,
became an independent,
and affiliated with the LP
for the last few months of his tenure.
Amash flirted with a run for
the LPs presidential nomination
in 2020 before choosing to
drop out of consideration.
Despite not holding an official position
in the party's leadership,
he is its best known member.
In the wake of the recent scandal,
he chastised the New Hampshire affiliate
for what he called its horrible
messaging even as he said
attempts to remove its
leadership were illegitimate.
I'm committed to making
the Libertarian Party
a major contender
that consistently wins
elections, he wrote.
We must work together to
build a big tent party
that can take on the old parties
and defend the rights of the people.
Representative Justin Amash,
thanks for talking to Reason.
Thanks, Nick.
So you've written and
you've talked about the LP
as you see it or you insist
that it should be a major contender
that consistently wins elections.
How are you feeling about that right now
in the wake of this resignation
of the Libertarian Party's
national chairperson
as well as two members
of the Libertarian National Committee?
I still feel positive.
It's a small party.
So when you have a small
party, you can have things
get upset pretty quickly
and pretty easily.
You know, a few people
shake up one state affiliate
and all of a sudden, a lot
of things start to crumble.
So it's not that surprising
when you have a party of this size,
but my goal is to make the
party much, much larger.
And when you have a much larger party,
things like this just
don't have the same impact.
I mean, when you look
at the Republican Party
or the Democratic Party, they
have crazy stuff going on
all the time and the
party doesn't fall apart
because it's big enough and robust enough.
So that's kind of a success story, right?
Their parties fall apart
because they are rife
with liars and hypocrites.
The Libertarian Party falls
apart because people disagree.
Yeah, I mean, it's small.
It's not that the party is falling apart.
It's that the party doesn't
really have an identity yet.
Okay.
You know, it doesn't
have a clear identity.
Let's talk about that in a second.
I want to ask, in a tweet that came out
right after all of this stuff
between the national party
and particularly things going
on in the Libertarian Party
of New Hampshire came out, you wrote
I think what was a perfectly
balanced kind of discussion.
You said that there was a due
process violation on the part
of the national party or some
people in the national party.
What due process got mucked up in this?
Well, it didn't seem to me
that you could just go off
and start a new state affiliate
and claim that it was the
legitimate state affiliate
without going through proper channels.
You can't just have one
state party chairman
go off and do that.
And it doesn't reflect
on my opinion of, like,
do I agree with the chairman
philosophically or not?
I had plenty of concerns about
the way the Libertarian Party
of New Hampshire was running
its social media accounts
and other things that were going on.
But at the same time,
you have to go through the proper process.
And if we don't like what's going on
with the state affiliate, the thing you do
is bring it to the attention
of the party at large.
You might bring it to the attention
of the Libertarian National Committee.
You definitely bring it to attention
of people within the state,
but you don't just run off
and form a new state
affiliate and say, well,
this is the new party and we're gonna also
take the resources, by
the way, of the old party
and lock out the executive committee
that was elected at the previous election.
So in the same statement about it,
you talked about horrible
messaging and edgelording
coming from people running,
particularly the social media account
of the Libertarian Party of New Hampshire.
What were the examples of that?
or what were the horrible
messages that were being said?
Oh, there was one about
John McCain's brain tumor.
Right, yeah, McCain's brain
tumor saved more lives
than Anthony Fauci, something like that.
Yeah, something like that.
There was another one about child labor.
There were a lot of examples,
and the person who was
allegedly doing the tweets
through the party account was also
putting out some pretty crazy
personal tweets as well.
So, you know, there was a
lot of horrible messaging.